[Music]
shortly after 10 pm impd southeast
district officers responded to a report
of a traffic accident in the 1600 block
of lexington avenue
while enroute dispatch provided
additional information to officers
southeast 11 16 29 1629 for an accident
1630 lexington avenue two vehicles
unknown injuries on one of the drivers
eight hundred top six hundred
twenty nine world cup sixteen twenty
nine at twenty two five continued to
wrestle information accident 1630
lexington avenue the caller call back
stating that one of the drivers of the
vehicles the black male red jacket
started exposing himself at the location
he was about to lexington avenue another
call came in saying the mail's just out
in the street yelling
control 1625
this accident on lexington the caller
stated that the intoxicated male in the
red buick left and he's injured he was
lasting southbound on state in a red
buick
with the help of witnesses arriving
officers located the red buick in the
1600 block of woodland avenue
the driver later identified as 31 year
old malik hill ran from officers into an
alley
officers repeatedly told him to stop but
hill did not comply
hill fired multiple shots from a handgun
at pursuing officers
one impd officer was shot
another impd officer then discharged his
service weapon striking hillary
right here
[Music]
i'll just try giving backs here i need
back up down
that might be him right there yep
yep get up next to him buddy
stick your hands out the window
stick your hands out the window
get out stop please stop please
it's all i got one running it's gonna be
wonderful
stop reaching motherfucker shoot you
stop reaching i'm gonna shoot you
[Music]
good time to get it tommy
[Music]
drop the gun
one
we are one block
north of woodlawn in the alley
where's the suspect
multiple privately owned security
cameras captured hill firing at officers
and then running east and crossing south
state avenue
get back
good
up
additional privately owned security
cameras captured an injured hill walking
across an alley and jumping a
homeowner's fence
me
impd officers and indiana state police
established a large perimeter to search
for hill
with the assistance of multiple
residents and a drone impd swat officers
located hills shortly after 11 pm in the
area of 900 dawson street
medics with the swat team and tactical
ems provided hill medical aid
he is expected to survive his injuries
the handgun he'll use was found near
where he was located
hill was arrested for one outstanding
warrant for a parole violation for a
robbery and possession of a firearm by a
serious violent felon
on march 8 2022 the marion county
prosecutor's office charged hill with
the following
two counts of attempted murder
one count of unlawful possession of a
firearm by a serious violent felon
six counts of resisting law enforcement
one count of criminal mischief mr hill
is presumed innocent and less and until
proven guilty in a court of law
officer mangan suffered a potentially
life-threatening gunshot wound to the
neck
officer mengen's condition has improved
but he faces a long road to recovery no
other officers or civilians were injured
in this incident
this incident is being investigated by
impd's critical incident response team a
separate and independent investigation
will be conducted by impd's internal
affairs unit to ensure compliance with
department policy
the marion county prosecutor's office is
being consulted throughout the
investigative process
this incident will be reviewed by the
civilian majority use of force review
board this occurs after the conclusion
of the criminal process
you